so um the big announcement in astronomy
over the last few weeks is the discovery
of a huge new ring around saturn
absolutely enormous far bigger than the
existing rings i mean it's kind of
interesting and and there's a theory as
to where it comes from that it's
probably um there's one of the one of
the moons of saturn shares the same
orbit as this enormous ring a moon
called phoebe um and it's thought
probably this
new ring is material that was ejected
from phoebe when something smashed into
phoebe and in fact if you just add up
the total amount of stuff that has to be
in this ring to give you some idea of
how diffusive it is even though it's
spread out over this enormous region of
space it's actually only about sort of
one craters worth of dust one crater's
worth of bits and pieces um so it's
probably something smashed into phoebe
through
dug out a new crater and the material
was ejected in that crater is now
forming this ring
saturn's entire ring and satellite
system is probably one of the most
interesting parts of the solar system
there's there's lots of stuff going on
out there saturn's
got over 60 moons or little moonlits as
well as this big large ring system and
if you were to actually go and look at
the rings in detail you'd find that
they're not they're certainly not a
solid object they're made up of lots and
lots of little particles ranging from
microscopic little dust particles up to
big boulder size chunks of rock and
mostly ice really and they line up in a
really flat
circle around the planet so to scale
they actually are thin as a piece of
paper
so it's amazingly thin even though they
go very very far away from the planet
and the rings change their angle to us
so sometimes we see the rings as this
big brilliant circle around the planet
and sometimes they're actually angled
flat as they just were at the beginning
of this year so sometimes you can't see
it which confused galileo to no end when
he first
found these 400 years ago one of the
things he could never quite figure out
was saturn because he said his telescope
was so crude and so simple that you
really couldn't get a decent picture of
saturn with it and so he concluded that
saturn probably had ears he could see
these bits sticking out the side and he
described them as ears it was only much
later that it was realized it was a
complete ring system around it you've
show gala if you show galileo the
pictures you get you know you point the
hubble space telescope at saturn the
amazing pictures you get with it he will
be truly astounded
the really really spectacular images of
saturn have come from the hugely
successful cassini mission so this one's
one of my favorites
so what you're looking at is just a
portion of saturn's ring system and you
can start to see really how thin this
ring system is and it's curving around
here but what's neat about this picture
in my mind is that in one snapshot you
get a view of some of the other
interesting parts of of the the saturn
ring system so one is this tiny little
moon here um
uh i can't remember the name of it
but you can see that it's really quite
small it's really quite irregular but
behind is the glory of saturn's moon
system which is titan
and titan is again one of the most
interesting parts of the solar system
you see that this picture here is hazy
and it's hazy because titan actually has
an atmosphere and not just a little thin
atmosphere a real proper thick
atmosphere made mostly out of nitrogen
and other gases like that so it makes it
one of the prime spots in the solar
system where we'd love to go and look
for signs of really primitive life
so hitching a ride on cassini right at
the beginning of the missions was a
separate probe called huygens that probe
was launched into the atmosphere
sent down information as it streamed
down through the atmosphere and was
designed to actually land with a thud on
the surface of titan and send back
information about what it landed in
so it was completely unclear whether it
would land in an ocean and float around
or whether it would land on solid ground
it turns out it landed on something
i think
was best described as creme brulee so
something a bit um bit with a bit of
give in it but with a bit of a crust as
well so one thing about saturn is that
it's not very dense it's the least dense
planet in the entire solar system in
fact it's less dense than water so if we
could find a body of water as
big as we needed to plop saturn right in
it saturn would actually float in that
water saturn also has my favorite moon
which is memos and i like it because
it's rocky it's got a lot of craters on
it but there's one huge crater that's
about a third of the diameter and it
looks like the death star
so it's the death star moon
so this one is even even better this is
my my real favorite picture of saturn
and again this is sent back from the
cassini probe
and what you're seeing is saturn in
eclipse so cassini is actually sitting
behind
saturn and the sun is on the other side
so just as if on earth sometimes the
moon gets in in front of us between us
and the sun and we get an eclipse that's
what you're seeing here
saturn is eclipsing the sun so you're
seeing it backlit so the rings are being
backlit some of that light is scattering
off so we do actually see the dark side
of saturn through scattered light
and you see this wonderful wonderful
effect of the ring system and you see
how layered it is
and how it extends out and even to
really really fuzzy rings uh much
further out
but but the very best part of this
picture in my mind gives us a little
perspective is this little spot here and
it's not it's not a spot on my computer
screen if we zoom in a little further
you see it here you see it's actually a
little round blob and that's the earth
that's the earth scene from billions of
miles away
and again really just shows us what a
tiny little insignificant spot we are in
the universe
but how lucky we are to be able to send
out these probes and send back
information like this